but how can we manage daily pain without having to take Tylenol or leave your ad bill or any over the
counter? Artica cream helps a little but what else might be helpful? So we've addressed this
because pain can be an issue with people with cancer, right? So how do you address pain from a
natural perspective? Well there are things like artica creams, there are artica things that you could
take orally, you could take artica as an herb orally or you could take artica folio path orally.
Now they tend to be helpful with minor pain issues. Also you could think of anything that's not that
as an anti-inflammatory, like your flavonoids, like the curcumid, the Vazuela, the resveratrol,
the EGCG, from green tea extract, the white willow bark, any of the other barks,
um of course it did. Those can be helpful but again mainly for more minor pain.
There isn't going to be, you know, anything from a natural perspective that's really going to
work as quickly as a pain medication. The only other thing that I would suggest is maybe thinking
of the marijuana product. CBD really doesn't, isn't a pain reducer. It can help with inflammation
that's in the brain maybe but not elsewhere. THC is the psychoactive for a marijuana
and that has been shown to be helpful with pain. However it has other side effects, not many people
like feeling loopy but it can help with pain at night because you're going to sleep anyhow. So
taking a THC product prior to sleep, maybe an hour before bed, it can help a person fall asleep,
it can help a person stay asleep and it can help a person stay asleep if they wake up because of
pain so it can help decrease pain and help a person get through the night. But most people don't
like to take the THC products during the day because you feel kind of loopy and out of it and nobody
likes that I don't like to feel that way. So um but from a natural perspective there are a lot of
things that are going to touch pain like a non-steroidal anti-inflammatory or prescription medication
unfortunately.